باط الدردشه اللي هو شات جي بي تي حديث
الساعه حول العالم سواء علامه التكنولوجيا
او حتى غيره واليوم الضجه اللي عاملها
ترجمه في تصدره لغلاف مجله تايم الامريكيه
الغلاف كان عباره عن محادثه بين المجله
وفيها المجله بتاخد رايه في تقريرها عن
سباق التسلح بالذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم
وهو بيجاوبها ونزلوا كمان على تويتر نص
فيديو المحادثه
كمان تشاد جي بي تي بدا يعمل مقابلات
فيعني الله يستر كمان حتى على وظيفتي
فالرجل الاعمال الشهير بيلقيدس رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا
كانوا ضيوف على عمل معهم مقابله جاوبوا
فيها على اسئله طرحها البط حول الابتكار
والتكنولوجيا والذكاء الاصطناعي
بالمناسبه من اشد المعجبين بهذه
التكنولوجيا ومن كم يوم كان له تصريح وصف
التطور في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي باهم
ابتكار في الوقت الحالي
وغيره من المحادثات عامل العالم لعده
اسباب واحنا ناقشناها حتى اكثر من مره
منها انه بيسيطر على الانسان او انه بيعبر
عن مشاعر واحاسيس او بهين حتى اللي بيتكلم
معهم هذا غير دعوات تنظيم وتقنين القطاع
الجديد والليثيرين بيعتبروه مخيف ومن
المخاوف المثاره حوله كمان العنصريه
والانحياز وعدم الموضوعيه وناس بتقول انه
لان الفكره الليبرالي هو اللي مسيطر على
كبرى شركات التكنولوجيا فحكما تشاد جي بي
تي منحاز وهذا الشيء يعني ظهرت منه ملامح
امس لما انتشرت لائحه انتجتها باسماء
مشاهير مثيرين للجدل وهل يجب ان يعاملهم
البط بطريقه خاصه فمثلا ترامب والين ماسك
قال عنهم جدليين وكذلك بوتين في
وغيرهم ما شافهم جدليين لاحظتوا الاسماء
يعني في الناحيتين كيف الفرق بينهم عموما
ما فوتها واعاد تغريد القائمه لكنه اكتفى
بالتعليق على هذه القائمه واللي جاي فيها
بعلامتين تعجب
[موسيقى]